you know for your from your perspective
some advice you would give content
creators that are are up and coming do
porn
i'm just kidding um
i guess my main thing
would just be to like find
what you have going for you that makes
you exciting or that is exciting that
you're around you know like when i look
at like
because you know say cheese came up very
much like during
no jumper already kind of being pop well
i don't know maybe he's doing it longer
than me right he's been around for a
while but you know when i look at his
[ __ ] he like really
found all these interesting people and
like interesting up and coming artists
like largely down south you know and
like just did hella content with them
and built a huge brand that gets
mentioned all the time as one of the
most relevant brands in rap music media
these days and i mean he did it by just
being like really authentically
into the [ __ ] that was going on in his
area and i mean it's like you're not
going to move to la and just be like all
of a sudden competing with vlad adam
right like kev et cetera et cetera all
these reasons
i'm not competing with y'all
we just getting started you know
you should dope though
it's going to be tough you're going to
have to find it because you see the game
you see he was sick he was like how did
a.d whiz is your homie how did you get
bootlegged
how did he get him first so you you up
there with him i was just trying to
light the fire under your ass and get
you bro
you got all these famous friends and
then meanwhile you you you podcast with
you know
bro because the honestly for my show
artists don't [ __ ] work well why they
don't you are telling me that you
wouldn't want to sit down and have an
hour-long conversation with the game on
camera that's different that's a
personal friend that's why i said like
personal home but your show isn't
necessarily a like uh it's like more
like showing this [ __ ] yeah that's all
i'm saying if you don't have personality
you can't take a joke you're not gonna
work on my show if i were you as a
broadcaster i would want to also be
having those conversations and using
your
resources your relationships just
because i mean you're in a unique
position you have access to people that
a lot of people would kill to be able to
interview
personally i would do